ah
muy buenos días bienvenidos a este
primer módulo de khan academy mi nombre
es
pedro aparicio y es un verdadero honor
el poder estar con todos ustedes el día
de hoy pues bien vamos a dar principio a
nuestro programa de certificación
correspondiente al ciclo escolar 2018
2019 2019 perdón con la capacitación del
módulo 1
el día de hoy hablaremos sobre qué es
khan academy y quiénes somos lo haremos
también sobre el programa de
certificación
comenzaremos a trabajar con esta
plataforma hablaremos también sobre
mejoras prácticas de implementación el
campeonato para el regreso a clases 2018
también hablaremos sobre la mentalidad
de crecimiento y los siguientes pasos
para la certificación
daremos inicio con carga de mí y quiénes
somos
nuestro objetivo principal es
[Música]
hablar sobre las diferentes estrategias
de maximizar los resultados académicos
en cada uno de tus alumnos ese es
nuestro final no tenemos ningún otro fin
si quieres tener acceso a esta
presentación te voy a dar un minuto un
par de minutos para que puedas tener la
presentación de manera digital
puedes abrir una ventana en tu
dispositivo en tu laptop en tu
computadora https dos puntos
y punto gl diagonal p g t mayúscula de
número 2 y d mayúscula
de esta manera podrás accesar a la
presentación digital inclusive la puedes
guardar en tus sitios favoritos y poder
tener acceso a esta presentación las
veces que tú quieras
en el momento que tú lo desees inclusive
si conoces a otros profesores que les
gustaría tener este reto de carne
academy sería excelente
yo creo que una de nuestras
de nuestros poderes como docentes y
hacer poder invitar a otros docentes
a trabajar de manera colaborativa
contigo con el único objetivo de mejorar
la educación en méxico desde cualquier
rincón de la república mexicana
[Música]
o en cualquier parte de latinoamérica
porque
no me estoy dando cuenta que tenemos
profesores
de sudamérica asistiendo a este webinar
ahora
espero que la mayoría de ustedes ya
puedan tener acceso a esta presentación
de manera digital en algunas de sus
ventanas en algún dispositivo móvil o
desde tu laptop
recuerden que si tienen alguna duda si
voy muy rápido muy lento pueden hacer
pueden hacérmelo saber por medio del
chat que veo que está muy activo
sigo dando unos segunditos más para ver
que estén todos presentes desde la
presentación digital
en dado caso que tengas algo muy
importante que hacer o tengas que salir
de este webinar recuerda que estaremos
enviados de las ligas la dirección
electrónica para que pueda tener acceso
inclusive a este a esta grabación
gracias a jorge zambrano arroz and the
sun
andy rodríguez leticia garcía uribe que
nos acompañan el día de hoy
está muy activo al chat por favor
mándanos todos tus dudas tus comentarios
y con gusto especialistas de carga
académica le estarán dando seguimiento a
tu petición
hoy vamos a continuar khan academy es
una organización
sin fines de lucro una educación
gratuita de clase mundial para todos
en cualquier momento y en cualquier
lugar en un ambiente 24/7 es decir 24
horas del día los 7 días de la semana
tenemos patrocinios bastante bastante
importantes como es fundación carlos
slim aquí méxico viola melinda gates de
eeuu también tenemos patrocinadores de
talla mundial como es google está tras
todo procesado le manda
y muchos patrocinadores alrededor del
mundo
el fundador de kan academia salman khan
hace este lanzamiento del sitio en
español desde el 2013 yo creo que eso es
muy importante para nosotros
es decir que no hay barreras es decir ya
no tenemos
esa dificultad donde el idioma inglés es
todo el contenido que encontrarás en
academia está completamente en español
la sede está en silicon valley
california
esta plataforma contiene
bastante es
materias como son matemáticas
programación ciencias y demás y como les
comentaba es una organización sin fines
de lucro
khan academy es una experiencia de
aprendizaje interactiva que se convierte
en el mejor aliado del profesor ya que
le permite ahorrar tiempo asignado
ejercicios y práctica personalizada a
sus alumnos nuestra plataforma es
gratuita divertida y está disponible las
24 horas del día
en cada cara de mi nos dedicamos a
reducir las barreras para lograr el
acceso global a la educación
si ustedes utilizan esos dispositivos
móviles
así
utiliza un tercer como
como empresa para que les dé acceso a
internet a sus datos si ustedes escriben
punto cero punto canal de punto org
ustedes pueden tener acceso a esta
plataforma de manera gratuita no se
gastarán tus datos de tu dispositivo
ya sea tu smartphone o algún otra
tableta
perfecto a continuación vamos a ver un
vídeo sobre esta experiencia que ha
tenido uno de nuestros estudiantes que
tenido acceso acceso a la plataforma de
khan academy
ah
no no
[Aplausos]
ella no está estudiando decía sigue
adelante
[Música]
calificaciones demasiado
son códigos binarios matemáticas
cálculos
[Música]
a los hermanos que sí se puede si se
puede
[Música]
muy bien qué les pareció esta historia
de alejandro espero que puedan hacer sus
comentarios vía chat yo creo que es
importante el tener otro tipo de
experiencias con otros estudiantes
que han tenido éxito que ha utilizado el
canal de mí para maximizar sus
resultados académicos poder ver desde
otra perspectiva desde otra y desde otro
enfoque
cómo podemos motivar como podemos
y darle mejores seguimientos darle ese
empoderamiento a los estudiantes y tener
pues
esa mejoría de sus habilidades de
matemáticas o de ciencias
cada academy
pues te da esta práctica personalizada
en diferentes materias y diferentes
diferentes grados escolares lo que va
desde el primero de primaria pues hasta
secundaria preparatoria
aquí encontrarás más de 10.000
ejercicios vídeos
artículos
estos artículos llevarán de la mano para
que tengas mejores resultados académicos
dependiendo de las habilidades
matemáticas como es trigonometría sumas
y restas de fracciones desniveles
básicos
estas matemáticas es para todos los años
escolares y también encontrarás
ejercicios de química física computación
y mucho mucho más
[Música]
que nos está ofreciendo khan academy el
día de hoy pues nos está ofreciendo un
programa de certificación una
certificación totalmente gratuita
y pues estamos invitando el día de hoy a
este programa de capacitación para este
nuevo ciclo escolar
por lo cual te invitamos que motivamos
te alentamos para que puedas unirte a
una comunidad de docentes inspiradores
en méxico
te invitamos a convertir convertirte en
un experto en el uso de nuestra
plataforma
qué es lo que debes de hacer muy bien
pues en primer lugar participar en tres
módulos de capacitación el día de hoy es
nuestro primer módulo
por cada módulo recibirás un certificado
que te acreditarán como un experto en el
uso de cada ave me contarás con todas
las herramientas para implementar con
éxito el uso de nuestra plataforma en tu
salón de clases
y tomarles comentó el día de hoy es
nuestro primer módulo llevaremos a cabo
los primeros pasos para que te registres
llevaremos a cabo un plan de acción para
este nuevo ciclo escolar
y llevaremos a cabo la implementación de
las mejores prácticas lineamientos
conoce la plataforma a fondo nuevas
características de la plataforma y al
final estaremos hablando sobre la
mentalidad de crecimiento y pues
algo padrísimo que que seguirá será el
módulo 2 que estará el campeonato eso se
llevará a cabo
en el mes de agosto y septiembre ahí
hablaremos en el siguiente webinar de lo
que es cómo comenzar como darle
seguimiento a este
a este reto
y de esta manera puedes ver las
diferentes estrategias para motivar a
tus alumnos durante el ciclo escolar
que en realidad dura solamente 10
semanas este este gran reto del
campeonato y luego el módulo 3 que es
esta en octubre noviembre y diciembre
y estaremos dándole seguimiento pues
para reconocer esos esfuerzos esos
logros que vayas alcanzando tus
estudiantes y tú como profesor también
qué necesitas para obtener tu primer
certificado de académico
bueno pues necesitamos participar en un
webinar ya lo estás haciendo ahorita
e
creamos para la clase asignar contenido
y completar la tarea asignada eso es de
vital importancia
para poder tener acceso a tu primer
certificado
en can academy estamos conscientes del
esfuerzo que haces para alcanzar
objetivos con tus estudiantes
en tu escuela en tu colegio es por eso
que nosotros estamos certificando a
profesores interesadas en mejorar la
educación y pues eso hay que darle un
reconocimiento bastante bastante amplio
tendremos horas de capacitación
podrás unirte a una comunidad de
docentes innovadores docentes
interesados
en encontrar nuevas estrategias nuevas
herramientas digitales y de esta manera
poder tener mejores logros dentro y
fuera del salón de clases
algo muy importante este recibirá su
apoyo de especialistas del equipo de
khan academy mexico en todo momento hay
correos electrónicos ahorita por medio
del chat puedes
decirnos qué dudas puedes tener qué
inquietudes tienes y nosotros estamos
aquí para apoyarte
programa de capacitación e información
clave bueno pues es importante el
registro tienes que llenar este
formulario con tu correo de khan academy
para recibir conocimiento para tu
esfuerzo y toda la información del
programa
es de suma importancia
tengas que hacer este registro para
nosotros darle seguimiento
a todas tus dudas y nosotros en nuestra
plataforma saber que tú estás ahí
dando tareas
creando una nueva clase para tus
estudiantes también tenemos el documento
con información del programa
hay que vamos a ir actualizando vamos a
ir añadiendo información
agregando herramientas digitales para
este programa de seis meses
y bueno pues para crear una cuenta
tienes que accesar a ese punto que
arranca de mi punto org y para cualquier
problema de soporte técnico ahí está la
dirección y con mucho mucho gusto
estaremos atendiendo a tus dudas oa tus
preguntas
en este momento tenemos a maría luisa
valerio que nos comenta que tiene cuatro
años usando hand academy con sus
estudiantes y nos dice que es una
herramienta que les ha facilitado el
aprendizaje los temas los puedes
seleccionar o recomendar directamente
con la misión que ellos tienen en su
clase pues excelente marianistas
bienvenida a bordo de este barco que se
llama khan academy y por favor sigamos
haciendo sus comentarios
para ir conociendo a todas las personas
que tenemos hoy en este webinar también
tenemos a ver las arrolló dice la
plataforma es una herramienta útil para
el estudiante siempre y cuando se
motiven y lo ayudemos a motivar para
darles sabor y emocionarse por los
contenidos en mi caso matemáticas es
fundamental la motivación es fundamental
la visión que nosotros tenemos como
docentes y nosotros nos involucramos y
nos sentimos realmente apasionados por
lo que hacemos pues esos estudiantes se
van a contagiar y van a poder accesar a
otro tipo de material a otro tipo de
herramientas tecnológicas y pues se
maximizan los resultados académicos muy
bien pues vamos a continuar
lo que sigue es el registro
voy a dar tres minutos
o ustedes me van dando la pauta en el
chat para que puedan hacer el registro
ahora mismo pueden ingresar desde su
laptop o dispositivo móvil a este a esta
liga a esta dirección la electrónica
en la pantalla están viendo el url para
que puedan obtener acceso y registrarse
para nosotros carne acá de mí es de
vital importancia que ustedes hagan el
registro
recuerden que todos estos recursos son
totalmente gratuitos y todo está en
español
y lo único que les estamos pidiendo es
hacer este registro para darle
seguimiento a sus clases a sus
contenidos
y poderlos motivar poderlos apoyar en
cualquier duda que ustedes tengan
cuando vayan creando estas clases
virtuales en pleno siglo 21
[Música]
es crucial
el utilizar nuevas tecnologías nuevas
plataformas
para ir dándole a nuestros estudiantes
las habilidades que necesitan para
enfrentarse a un mundo cada día más
globalizado
por favor nuevamente ingresen a esta
dirección electrónica para que lleven a
cabo su registro
y nosotros aquí encarna academy mexico
poderle dar seguimiento
a todas sus clases virtuales que vayan
creando
que desarrollen
todas las misiones las materias los
temas que vayan desarrollando y nosotros
estar al pendiente de ustedes
nos están mandando saludos desde el
komander plantea el aeropuerto
tenemos también aquí algunos estudiantes
de prepa línea de láser lo cual
esta es una herramienta fundamental
grandiosa para que ustedes puedan tener
acceso a este material
las veces que quieran en un ambiente
24/7 24 horas 7 días de la semana en su
tiempo en sus horarios no importa si es
todo matutino o vespertino no puedes
tener acceso cuando gustes
también estamos recibiendo saludos del
conalep oaxaca
tenemos ahora rodríguez
nájera del color el plantel
hasta wha kang
[Música]
gracias julio césar valenzuela pobre por
estar registrado ya
estoy dando un par de minutos más para
que terminen su registro
si tienen algún problema técnico con el
registro si les pediría que sean muy
muy cuidadosos con el url
e
[Música]
tener mucho cuidado por ejemplo es g
punto g l diagonal un mayúscula
con mayúscula 151 mayúscula
de esta manera tendrás acceso sin ningún
problema para este registro
hola
cabe mencionar que es importante
de nuestro trabajo colaborativo a
nuestro colegio en nuestra escuela
ustedes pueden compartir esta liga para
que sus compañeros docentes también
puedan tener acceso a la plataforma y
también poderles dar seguimiento no
puede haber envidias en este en nuestra
labor docente nosotros como docentes
como profesores estamos comprometidos
a desarrollar nuevas estrategias nuevas
nuevas pedagogías en el salón de clases
y pues una de ellas es compartir el
conocimiento que vamos adquiriendo desde
la certificación y pues al mismo tiempo
estamos reforzando esos nuevos
conocimientos que vamos adquiriendo a lo
largo
de nuestra carrera docente
perfecto en el chat lo veo están muy
activos todos me están diciendo que ya
están registrados
pues vamos a continuar ahora con el
programa del webinar de cardin
este programa es un documento de google
que es importante que lo pongan también
en sus favoritos
para que en todo momento puedan tener
los diferentes pasos que tienen en
carnac a demi para la certificación
nuevamente les pido de favor accesar a
este programa abriendo otra ventana en
la parte superior de su computadora
tengan cuidado al escribir la dirección
electrónica g o punto g en diagonal y
r mayúscula 8
jota mayúscula z y s y aquí encontrarás
toda la información sobre los siguientes
webinars sobre la plataforma sobre los
retos y algo importantísimo
sobre el campeonato qué es
un programa padrísimo que te va a
permitir a lo largo de 10 semanas
participar y tus estudiantes se
motivarán con diferentes
diplomas digitales insignias digitales
que les permitirán ir alcanzando nuevos
puntajes en los diferentes retos
nos comenta alonso morán se nota que es
una plataforma muy interactiva
nos comenta que es nuevo en esta
plataforma no soy muy buena en la
informática pero haré mi mejor esfuerzo
en la segunda vez que me registro
excelente bienvenido alonso moral por
participar activamente en esta
plataforma de khan academy esto que nos
comenta alonso es muy importante no
necesita ser un experto en programación
o ser un ingeniero en sistemas para
tener acceso a esta plataforma
de nuestro buscador de khan academy es
muy sencillo es muy amigable es sencillo
de usar lo único que tienes que hacer es
atreverte a darle clic
y ayer
investigando poco a poco de los
diferentes contenidos que te vas
encontrando allí es muy interactiva es
muy amigable como les acabo de decir lo
único que tienes que hacer es atreverte
dar ese pasito de hacer algo diferente
algo innovador y listo
ya estás del otro lado ya estarás
innovando
sus clases y los más beneficiados de
todo esto pues serán tus estudiantes
serán tus alumnos que estarán más
motivados más enganchados
en aprender matemáticas ciencias e
inclusive programación porque no
pues vamos a comenzar
hacer
siempre trabajo con que acerca de mí
lo primero que tienes que hacer es crear
una cuenta y configurar tus clases
qué es lo que tienes que hacer es abrir
una ventana nueva y escribir en ese
punto k h
n a c a d
m y punto hereje
y darle clic
de esta manera comenzarás a crear tu
cuenta de khan academy
y ya configurar tus clases
muy sencillo muy práctico es una
plataforma amigable e interactiva y
fácil de encontrar contenidos
qué es lo que tienes que hacer es dar
clic en ese punto khan academy punto org
y estás del otro lado
con estos pasos sencillos estarás
innovando tus clases ya sea a nivel
primaria a nivel secundaria a nivel
bachillerato y por qué no a nivel
universitario tenemos nosotros todos los
niveles
en ciencias en física química
matemáticas e inclusive programación les
voy a dar nuevamente un par de minutos
para que vayas creando tu cuenta de
encarnar en mí
saludos chávez duran del conalep amealco
querétaro
nos pregunta si en eeuu tierras moras
hasta qué fecha se puede registrar
para registrar a compañeros que faltan
lo pueden hacer la próxima semana
puede ser en un par de semanas con
inicia el ciclo escolar en dos meses en
realidad ustedes pueden registrarse
cuando quieren lo importante aquí el
reto que los estamos invitando el día de
hoy es para que participen en el reto
campeonato que durará 10 semanas y bueno
pues ahí habrá previos importantes para
ustedes y por supuesto una certificación
que los avala como expertos en carne
academy
nos pregunta patricia pérez
si es necesario crear una nueva cuenta
que ya tiene pues seguir con la que ya
tiene no es necesario crear una otra
cuenta lo que sí puedes crear es otra
clase
inclusive si eres un profesor de
secundaria o de preparatoria e imparte
es más de dos materias tres materias no
tienes ningún problema en cada académico
es creas tres clases diferentes
y pues vamos agregando diferentes
material de acuerdo a las necesidades de
sus estudiantes puedes alinear
todo este contenido de acuerdo a tu
programación de acuerdo a tu currículo
es importante mencionar también
que khan academy es solamente una
herramienta de apoyo los verdaderos
expertos de su materia pues son ustedes
ustedes van a impartir con su libre
cátedra
planear dar su clase como ustedes gusten
de acuerdo a lo que sus coordinadores
les vayan comentando les vayan diciendo
y cada academia es simple y
sencillamente un apoyo una herramienta
tecnológica que les permitirá mejorar
esas habilidades dentro y fuera del
salón de clases
le recuerdo que cualquier duda si están
atorados en alguna parte pueden utilizar
el chat y con mucho gusto estaremos
resolviendo todas sus dudas
gracias normalmente pero todos esos
personas que están muy activas en este
chat
wjan américa infante lugo olga liliana
lópez velázquez
tenemos otro comentario podría aplicarla
para clases particulares en mi casa pues
la respuesta es obvia claro que sí
inclusive para tus hijos si están en
secundaria si están en bachillerato si
conoces algún sobrino
la poda sobrina que ésta ha tenido
dificultades en física en química en
matemáticas por supuesto que puedes
utilizar nuestra plataforma de khan
academy
saludos desde pueblo juana más tranza
[Música]
es incansable de ponerle 121-129 de
reynosa un saludo desde la ciudad de
méxico te enviamos un fraterno saludo
rafael guzmán ruiz os está preguntando
cómo se utiliza la app sin datos si la
compañía que te provee el servicio de
internet es telcel
cuando utilizas khan academy no estaba
utilizando tus datos
al tener acceso a todo este material
será totalmente gratuito
e inclusive sin utilizar tus datos
yo creo que es una excelente oportunidad
para acceder a otro tipo de contenidos
de materiales de vídeos de ejercicios de
forma gratuita
que en el córdoba nos manda saludos
desde chile saludo fraterno que dentro
desde méxico para chile
y estoy dando unos segundos más para que
terminen de registrarse de crear una
cuenta en cada cadena punto org
y les puedo recomendar
una vez que tengan creado su cuenta y
configurado sus clases pues guardarse
este sitio darle en favoritos y de esta
manera la próxima vez que quieran tener
acceso
pues con un simple que llegan a sus
clases virtuales
y cuál es el objetivo de canacar dem y
cuál es nuestro nuestro coro
institucional pues incrementar el
aprendizaje en los alumnos ese es
nuestro objetivo
esa es nuestra meta principal
saludos a jose vistas tres autores de
venezuela
no se está preguntando
que si se ha perdido de muchos del
webinar
espero que no de todos modos estaremos
enviando
y las ligas
para para las personas que lo quieran
ver nuevamente
inclusive compartir con otros docentes
de su colegio de su escuela
y poderlo ver las veces que sean
necesarias
por eso es importante que estén
registrados en nuestra plataforma pues
para poderles enviar estas
notificaciones estos correos
electrónicos con nuevos artículos con
nuevos contenidos
un nuevo material para sus clases
inclusive hay artículos
sobre nuevas estrategias de enseñanza
que eso
es un extra es un plus
para ser muy asertivos en el salón de
clases y bueno pues si ya está de lado
en el tablero de control ustedes pueden
darse cuenta que
para registrarse hasta
la parte de los estudiantes dándole clic
en y diciendo aquí maestros o inclusive
padres de familia
ustedes se pueden unir simple y
sencillamente dándole en continuar con
su cuenta de gmail lo pueden hacer
también con facebook o desde cualquier
correo electrónico y crear su cuenta
una vez que ya accedieron
a su cuenta
de cabeza de mí pues le van a dar un
nombre a su clase como puede ser segundo
semestre de la maestra laura rodríguez
quinto de primaria profesor pedro
aparicio como ustedes gusten nombrar su
clase
la mejor clase de matemáticas del mundo
porque no
y le da en siguiente
ah
al darle siguiente pues van a agregar un
tema una materia
[Música]
matemáticas elementales aritmética pre
álgebra fundamentos de álgebra la
geometría trigonometría estadística y
probabilidad cálculo diferencial
o pueden ir directamente a matemáticas
por grado desde 1º de primaria esto es
increíble las nuevas tecnologías nos
están dando la oportunidad de poder de
poder llegar a más alumnos
en cualquier parte de la república
mexicana de latinoamerica siempre y
cuando tengas acceso a internet y si
tienes una empresa como telcel no
estarás utilizando tus datos al estar
trabajando en khan academy
desde el primero de primaria hasta el
tercer semestre de bachillerato aquí
están todos los temas alineados
el programa oficial de láser
y pues también tenemos ciencias como es
biología química física ingeniería
eléctrica
y demás
juana más trans o nos comenta es muy
gratificante que los alumnos quieran
utilizar la tecnología para su
crecimiento escolar totalmente de
acuerdo totalmente de acuerdo forma
hoy en día en pleno siglo 21 el alumno
debe tener estas habilidades digitales y
utilizarlas en su beneficio
prácticamente niños de quinto sexto de
primaria están accediendo a las redes
sociales como un dispositivo móvil con
un teléfono inteligente pues hay que
aprovecharla es hay que aprovechar esta
tecnología
desde un enfoque positivo desde un
ambiente escolar académico
y seguir desarrollando pensamiento
matemático ciencias porque no
felicidades cuando más trans estás muy
activa en nuestro chat también nos dice
solo falta difundir más esta herramienta
totalmente de acuerdo mi estimado a
juana por eso estamos haciendo este
webinar en khan academy para darlo a
conocer a todos los maestros de méxico
ya sea en después las públicas como en
colegios particulares
esta herramienta está para todos y
también depende de ustedes que compartan
esta herramienta con sus compañeros en
la escuela con su director con su
coordinador
con su supervisor académicas
porque recuerden que todo esto está
alineado de acuerdo al programa oficial
de la sep
ah
y lo que ustedes necesiten en cuanto a
temas pues ustedes pueden ir
investigando
pueden ir investigando buscar sus temas
planearlo
que sea parte fundamental de su
planeación académica
sobre todo para profesores de
bachillerato
que está muy alineado a su programa de
estudios
alonso moral
nos comenta puedo colocar la url de khan
academy debo colocar en los recuadros
sí correcto donde dice maestros aquí
nos comenta que ya irse al azar no se
pueden dar las mismas metodologías de
enseñanza de antes a los actuales que
van a ser los profesionistas del futuro
y karnak a danny es un gran apoyo para
ellos gracias por tu comentario y ahí
efectivamente
en el año 2018 pues ya estamos hablando
de asignaturas que se dan de manera
interdisciplinaria debemos de apoyarlos
en la tecnología en nuevas herramientas
tecnológicas herramientas emergentes que
van a maximizar los resultados
académicos como este webinar
no nos va a acercar a la tecnología
y al mismo tiempo no tienes que ser un
especialista
en sistemas computacionales o ser
ingeniero en computación
simple y sencillamente con un buscador
de web
con tu laptop e inclusive con tu tele
teléfono inteligente con un par de
clicks tienes acceso a la web academy
a
saludos familia no es su lema nada
enríquez que nos acompaña desde tijuana
[Música]
y nos comenta que tiene el gusto de
estar en este programa desde que se
inició aquí en méxico cada semestre lo
utilizo para mis clases de matemáticas
excelente felicidades por estar
actualizando te por estar innovando por
estar haciendo algo diferente
y no pasa nada si puedes crear una clase
y luego borrar de un luego volver a
crear otra nosotros estamos convencidos
de una mentalidad de crecimiento es
decir puedes cometer errores y de esos
errores aprender cómo hacerlo mejor la
próxima vez lo importante es intentarlo
no vemos un fracaso escolar' aquí solo
vemos oportunidades de innovar y
desarrollar habilidades matemáticas
a fin de motivar a nuestros alumnos
de motivarlos a que cada día es una
oportunidad de aprender algo nuevo
una vez que ya te has creado tu cuenta y
ha agregado una clase
khan academy te va a dar un código
para esa clase que acabas de crear
cuando ya tengas tus estudiantes el
número de alumnos con sus nombres
para tu siguiente semestre para los
siguientes y preescolar les vas a
compartir este código
de manera que ingresara khan academy y
van a teclear este código y
automáticamente tendrán acceso a esa
clase virtual que tú has creado
y listo de la clase creaba
qué es lo que sigue bueno puedes
encontrar ejercicios vídeos y artículos
para tu clase asignarlo a otros
estudiantes
en tu tablero de control podrás ver la
página de tu clase para dar seguimiento
al avance de cada uno de tus estudiantes
esto de una manera muy sencilla y muy
amigable
o
nos comenta crescenciano salina luís
dice a mí como como docente
khan academy me ha funcionado bastante
bien para mis estudiantes después de ver
los temas como reforzamiento excelente
práctica crecenciano pues muchos
profesores así es como vengan acá y para
reforzar esos temas que ya se estuvieron
dejando dentro del aula y es lo que a
continuación siguen mejores prácticas de
implementación
qué necesidades podrían cambiar khadem y
cubrir en mi clase
bueno
puesto práctica puede estar alineada a
una lección
la práctica puede ser guiada por el
mismo docente o inclusive puede ser una
práctica independiente es decir con esos
alumnos que les cuesta más trabajo ese
contenido
para esos alumnos que no les gusta mucho
participar en clase que quizás están un
poquito recién rezagados con el
contenido de matemáticas pues a ellos
puede ser una práctica independiente
un ejemplo de ello pues puede ser 2 a 3
veces por semana durante 20 minutos
recuerden que esto es un reforzamiento
no queremos que estén 34 horas ahí
haciendo esas prácticas con 20 minutos
es más que suficiente para reforzar ese
contenido
otro modelo puede ser el repaso
ya sea en la escuela puede ser en el
laboratorio de computación algunos
algunas escuelas tienen una hora o hasta
dos horas de computación de la semana
pues ahí pueden trabajar de manera
colaborativa con el profesor de
informática con la maestra de
informática y tener acceso a nuestra
plataforma
y revisión o remediación de una unidad
es decir pues ya vienen los exámenes hay
que hacer una revisión
hay que ser pues ese repaso para que los
estudiantes tengan buenos resultados en
sus evaluaciones
esto puede ser 2 a 3 veces por mes
durante todo el tiempo de la clase
otros docentes lo están manejando como
tarea es decir fuera de la escuela pero
explicado en clases y ya estaban la
frecuencia determinada por el maestro
pues ya desde acuerdo a las necesidades
de acuerdo a las características tanto
de los estudiantes como de su escuela
el cuarto modelo pues puede ser una
práctica individual en clase o fuera de
clase con ejercicios y a la frecuencia
es determinada por el docente puede ser
dos o tres veces a la semana dos o tres
veces por mes dependiendo de las
necesidades de sus estudiantes
entonces aquí tienen cuatro modelos
distintos de cómo poder utilizar nuestra
plataforma para motivar a los
estudiantes y ellos puedan incrementar
el aprendizaje
tanto de matemáticas o de ciencias
es importante llevar a cabo una
planeación un plan estratégico
con sus clases pues que ya están aquí a
la vuelta de la esquina
qué es lo que nosotros recomendamos pues
por lo menos elegir entre
que siguió 34 recursos por semana para
asignar a sus estudiantes en sus clases
hacer equipo con otros profesores del
mismo curso uno de los profesores se
enfocan en contenido a nivel de grado y
otro se enfoca en el contenido de repaso
debemos de romper estos
esas costumbres o esos enfoques
tradicionalistas de qué
yo conozco todo yo sé todo aquí lo que
yo hago con mis estudiantes
es todo lo que hago hoy en día el
enfoque
pedagógico está en trabajar de manera
colaborativa o de utilizar habilidades
de comunicación de colaboración de
pensamiento crítico utilizar la
creatividad la imaginación
como ustedes saben 23 cabezas piensas
más que una entonces cada vez que
tengas a otros compañeros sean tus
aliados pues tu proyecto se enriquecerá
mucho más
[Música]
puedes también crear tareas y revisarlas
para dar retroalimentación y si es de
manera colaborativa será mucho más
productivo
nos comenta para ver el romero el uso de
esta plataforma como herramienta de
enseñanza-aprendizaje permite que el
alumno se adentre de una forma más amena
a las matemáticas asimismo permite
generar el autoaprendizaje totalmente de
acuerdo para óleo pues si es de una
manera mucho más amena mucho más
divertido
el día de hoy nuestros estudiantes
tienen acceso a internet teléfonos
inteligentes y pues no creo que se vayan
a quejar si utilizar nuestra plataforma
gracias por audio gracias por todos tus
comentarios
xalbador terrones cuando será la próxima
capacitación
[Música]
pues no no
y pues el 14 de agosto será nuestro
siguiente webinar
gracias por tu interés y te esperamos
somos un grupo de profesores innovadores
apasionados por la educación que nuestro
único enfoque es dar nuevas herramientas
para que nuestros alumnos puedan
incrementar su aprendizaje
y cambiar la educación de méxico porque
no
es importante desarrollar un plan para
enganchar y motivar a sus a nuestros
estudiantes desarrollar desarrollo en su
propio plan para motivar a sus alumnos
cómo planea seguir el progreso de sus
alumnos cómo piensa celebrar sus logros
cómo puede motivar la perseverancia y la
excelencia en sus alumnos cómo va a
evaluar el desempeño y esfuerzo de sus
alumnos en kant academy todas estas
incógnitas
las resolvemos desde nuestra plataforma
es fácil una vez que ellos ya se
registraron en tu clase virtual darle
seguimiento a ese progreso entonces
en tus alumnos
juntos en el salón de clases o de manera
individual
o puedes hacer un contigo más cercano
con cada uno de ellos y celebrar sus
logros
eso es mera importante eso es motivante
para que ellos puedan seguir con el
siguiente nivel de matemáticas de física
y pues al mismo tiempo estaremos
motivando su esfuerzo su perseverancia
la excelencia que ellos vayan
desarrollando es un nivel escolar
y por qué no de acuerdo a los niveles de
exigencia en nuestra plataforma pues eso
puede ser un índice más para la
evaluación
de cada dos estudiantes y ya no esperar
al examen semestral para ver cómo van
para ver si están aprendiendo o no con
nuestra plataforma ustedes desde el
primer día desde el primer día pueden
darles seguimiento
al desempeño de cada uno de sus alumnos
y
muy bien pues uno de nuestros
y retos mayores es el campeonato
que será algo muy divertido algo muy
padre para todos nuestros profesores
para todos los estudiantes
y eso será
la patada de inicio a este nuevo ciclo
escolar 2018 2019
este es un programa gratuito de 10
semanas para impulsar el aprendizaje en
este regreso a clases al combinar
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
y prácticas de materias en cada cardemil
la clase entera aumenta su confianza y
su motivación
y tendrán clases participativas clases
enganchadas alumnos contentos de venir a
la escuela y querer alcanzar
logros increíbles increíbles dentro de
tu materia
para cuando es este reto las
inscripciones se abren el 13 de agosto
del 2018 el reto comienza en septiembre
y termina el 16 de noviembre
es importante recalcar que
a pesar que son 10 semanas
tú como profesor puedes participar dos
semanas no va a pasar nada
lo importante es que participes no es un
requisito indispensable es las 10
semanas pueden ser tres semanas pueden
ser cinco semanas
puede ser media hora pueden ser dos
horas
puedes invitar a otros profesores
si a lo mejor el inicio del ciclo
escolar fue muy pesado para tus
compañeros de trabajo para sus
directivos y quizás quieras participar y
solamente te enfocas en las últimas dos
semanas no importa y lo importante es
que participes que conozcan tus
estudiantes este reto
y que pueda
y motivarse a hacer algo diferente
la competencia es importante y hay que
preparar a nuestros estudiantes para ser
competitivos en un mundo cada día más
globalizado
en donde se llevará a cabo se llevará a
cabo en cualquier rincón de la república
mexicana y participa todos los
estudiantes de primaria bachillerato
pueden tener acceso simple y
sencillamente
con acceso a internet
y pues este campeonato está pensado para
motivar los estudiantes sin importar su
nivel académico
el programa se adapta fácilmente a todo
tipo de aula horario o ambiente escolar
recuerden pueden participar escuelas
públicas escuelas privadas
pueden participar estudiantes de la
ciudad de méxico- de monterrey de
guadalajara
escuelas rurales en oaxaca en guerrero
es un verdadero gusto ver a profesores
de tabasco y veracruz por toda la
república
aquí
y al mismo tiempo pues si estás
participando en el programa de
capacitación
vas a tener que participar en este reto
para lograr el segundo certificado
es muy muy importante este programa de
capacitación y el reto de campeonato
es estar dedicado a la segunda
certificación
es simple sencillo solo necesitas
invertir un par de horas en motivar a
tus alumnos a que se registren como
clase
y poder participar a lo largo de estas
10 semanas
es necesario que cubras las 10 semanas
no pueden ser dos semanas inclusive
puede ser una semana simple y siempre y
cuando estés registrado con nosotros y
puedas seguir participando en el
programa de capacitación
cuáles son los principios del campeonato
pues es para todos inspira confianza y
motiva el aprendizaje para todos los que
aprenden sin importar su nivel académico
o su condición socioeconómica promueve
una mentalidad de crecimiento en poder a
los maestros este es uno de mis palabras
favoritas
favoritas empoderar a los maestros es
fácil de implementar en una variedad de
aulas y ambientes escolares flexibles
los profesores saben mejor que motiva o
que les motiva a sus estudiantes hacer
del profesor un héroe
no necesitas ponerte de cabeza para que
tus estudiantes pongan atención en
clases con plataformas como la nuestra
de khan academy los maestros nos
sentimos motivados en tolerados a
mejorar nuestras prácticas pedagógicas
esto es justo esto es importante hablar
de la virtud de la justicia porque todos
sin importar su entorno escolar tienen
la oportunidad de participar
nuestro campeonato tiene reglas fáciles
de entender contenidos fáciles de
encontrar
y está muy detallado el programa es
divertido celebra el progreso del
individuo y de toda la clase con premios
digitales insignias digitales
integra elementos de sorpresa y momentos
de festejo
sobre todo a nivel primaria cada uno de
las respuestas correctas pues no ceder
más a sí mismo
en el tiempo y en hora
y conocer a eso que los estudiantes
celebran sus avances pues aquí tenemos
un vídeo que vamos a ver para ver como
alumnos de brasil festejan su progreso
para
[Aplausos]
as
que despareció la manera en que estos
estudiantes de brasil festejaron su
progreso con toda la clase es motivante
nosotros como docentes necesitamos
esa alegría esa chispa de los
estudiantes ese interés
por querer aprender por querer mejorar
sus prácticas académicas
que pueden participar en este campeonato
profesores y alumnos de primaria hasta
bachillerato de cualquier escuela
incorporada a láser en toda la república
mexicana
nuestro reto combina miles de ejercicios
gratuitos de khan academy con incentivos
de edición limitada para motivar
celebrar y premiar el esfuerzo de cada
estudiante sin importar su iberia
aquí tenemos el testimonio de manuel
maestra de matemáticas del conalep que
dice el logro más significativo es que
los estudiantes tienen ahora más interés
por aprender matemáticas lo hacen ahora
de una manera significativa orientada a
su vida real
excelente testigo de la doma de storm a
nivel
al final del camino nosotros buscamos
que los estudiantes tengan ese
aprendizaje significativo y lo puedan
aplicar en su vida cotidiana cuando van
a la tienda cuando van al súper al
supermercado y hacen
compras y puedes utilizar su cálculo
mental aplicar sus estrategias
matemáticas pues
en este
en este tono real en un contexto real de
su vida cotidiana
nos comenta eréndira nos queda lo
interesante es que no hay tiempos
afectados es libre y constante claro que
sí eréndira lo puedes
planear de acuerdo a tus necesidades a
tus tiempos eso es muy importante es una
plataforma muy muy flexible
miriam se le llamaba en rikers dice al
utilizar esta plataforma los alumnos se
vuelven independientes de su propio
aprendizaje
claro que sí llevan a cabo lo que es el
autoaprendizaje
e inclusive pueden llevar a cabo tener
lo que es la autoevaluación ellos van
metiendo su propio progreso
y se motiva en el vídeo tiempo
con la plataforma de khan academy puedes
celebrar todos los logros de tus
estudiantes premios semanales medallas
virtuales certificados y pósters para tu
clase
también puedes compartir los materiales
y recursos con otros profesores
inclusive padres de familia y
estudiantes de tu escuela o de toda tu
comunidad es importante involucrar a los
padres de familia para esos estudiantes
que se sienten rezagados o que creen que
no son buenos para las matemáticas por
ejemplo y ahí con el apoyo de los padres
de familia
y alcanzar logros
importantes
puedes también también abrir un club de
chaska de mí
puedes organizar una reunión en tu salón
de clases durante el recreo o al
terminar las clases para que los
estudiantes avancen en el campeonato es
una excelente idea
para seguir motivando a alumnos que ya
están interesados que quieren más que
quieren pasar al siguiente nivel puedes
abrir un club de canadá en bien por las
tardes
y es darle seguimiento y tener a tus
campeones de tu escuela
y se van a sentir identificados contigo
con su escuela y van a poder apoyar a
otros estudiantes que tengan
dificultades ya sean matemáticas o en
ciencias
aquí está la dirección electrónica para
tener acceso a este reto de campeonato
es campeonato un tocar academy punto org
ahora les voy a platicar un poquito
sobre la mentalidad de crecimiento que
es una estrategia que está utilizando la
plataforma de khan academy es decir
nosotros vemos
el cerebro como un músculo que necesita
ejercitarse
necesite ir al gym necesita hacer más
ejercicio en la medida que hacer más
ejercicio
va a estar más fuerte va a ser más
poderoso más creativo más imaginativo
va a tener un motor de mayor poder para
el crecimiento
tendrás estrategias para el éxito para
el éxito es decir
en un en un fracaso en un reto
encontrarás la habilidad para aprender
de tus fallas de tus errores modificarlo
y la próxima vez hacer lo mejor y
alcanzar el éxito
convirtiendo errores en oportunidades
nosotros creemos firmemente en que esto
es posible siempre y cuando puedas
ejercitar tu cerebro
y pues a lo largo de nuestro webinar
estaremos hablando de estrategias para
llegar a este éxito académico
también estaremos hablando sobre
síntesis y reflexión superando la
frustración
superando el miedo
y poder atrevernos a hacer cosas
diferentes cosas nuevas y ver siempre
hacia adelante hacia nuevas
oportunidades hacia nuevos retos
esto es posible teniendo una mentalidad
de crecimiento y nosotros en carnac a
demi estamos convencidos de que esto es
posible y el ejemplo
el ejemplo lo da el docente si nosotros
tenemos esta mentalidad de crecimiento
si nosotros nos atrevemos si hacemos a
un lado el miedo el fracaso y lo
convertimos en una oportunidad nuestros
alumnos seguirán nuestro
nuestro modelo también se atreverán
también dejará del miedo también dejarán
atrás la frustración
y una vez dejado a un lado el miedo la
frustración pues tendrán mayor éxito
estarán más motivados su autoestima se
desarrollará
y darán mejores resultados académicos
dentro y fuera del aula
dos preguntas nos preguntas sandra
aboytes nos van a asesorar y cuál sería
el punto de comunicación es decir correo
electrónico o página web claro que si
tenemos un correo electrónico que está
al inicio de la presentación y desde
allí nosotros estaremos dando
retroalimentación
y recuerden una vez que se registraron
que proporcionaron sus datos nosotros
estaremos asesorando de manera
personalizada a cada uno de los docentes
en la república mexicana no importa si
vives en tijuana en quintana roo en
veracruz
en puebla en 'hidalgo' nosotros
estaremos dándole seguimiento a todas
tus dudas
a todos tus comentarios a todas tus
quejas y por qué no también a tus
felicitaciones
nos pregunta contreras marco antonio que
si este torneo es similar al danés form
es muy parecido tendrá sus sus
características propias pero sí si has
participado en la restauró claro que
tienes una idea de cómo será nuestro
campeonato
[Música]
qué es lo que sigue
bueno tienen a otros compañeros que no
se han registrado en nuestra plataforma
pues deben estar registrados en un
programa de capacitación en el día de
hoy a muchos de ustedes llenaron este
formulario para recibir conocimiento
para tu esfuerzo e información del
programa
es importante entender el documento con
toda la información vamos a añadir
información clave a esta liga durante el
programa de seis meses es importante que
lo vean de manera periódica
y seguir los pasos el módulo 1 para
recibir tu primer certificado antes del
primero de septiembre
es decir que estará recibiendo su primer
certificado por parte del canal de mí
crear una cuenta en nuestra plataforma
los que participaron activamente el día
de hoy pues ya tienen esa cuenta con
nosotros asistir a dos eventos en vivo
en vivo perdón ya vienen
ya les dije las fechas de los siguientes
dos webinars
hacer una tarea y llenar el formulario
de registro
yo creo que este es una excelente
oportunidad para todos ustedes
certificarse
y cada calle me tiene prestigio a nivel
internacional
para cualquier duda o comentario o queja
sugerencia felicitación tendremos el
correo electrónico o la academy punto
org y con mucho gusto especialistas de
nuestra plataforma estarán resolviendo
sus dudas
y pues si estás activo en el chat
cualquier duda que tengas en este
preciso momento lo comentamos para
resolver todas tus dudas en este
instante
o no
entonces pregunta que cuándo será el
campeonato pues estará abierto desde el
13 de agosto para inscribirse
recuerden que ya tienen la presentación
al inicio del webinar instalada la
dirección electrónica para obtener
acceso
a la presentación de este webinar
y entre ellos está la página de
campeonato juntos khan academy punto org
en donde podrán inscribirse en el reto
del campeonato a partir del 13 de agosto
nos pregunta lorenzo alfredo garcía
macías que si recibirán información vía
correo electrónico es correcto
nos dice miriam su lema
gracias por esta nueva oportunidad de
crecimiento
de conocimientos no gracias a ustedes
por la oportunidad de estar
acompañándonos el día de hoy en este
webinar recuerden que siempre
el docente debe estar actualizándose
hay nuevas pedagogías hay nuevas
estrategias
hay nuevos enfoques pedagógicos y es
importante retomar nos es importante
actualizar nos en redes sociales en
plataformas
y estar
pues con nuevas herramientas dentro del
salón de clases no están tan
desprotegidos ante estos nuevos
estudiantes que muchos dicen que son
nativos digitales pues es un reto
importante el estar capacitando nos día
a día
y nosotros en can academia les brindamos
esa oportunidad de esta opción de
certificarse
y de desarrollar nuevas estrategias
pedagógicas con el uso de la tecnología
nos comentaba nos comentó también que
muchos de ustedes iniciar clases el 20
de agosto no hay un problema pueden
registrarse
22 de agosto si ustedes buscan el 25 de
agosto no hay ningún problema
y recuerden que son 10 largas semanas
para poderse registrar y participar en
los retos de este
concurso de campeonato
gracias por todos sus comentarios por
todas sus preguntas nos están diciendo
nos están preguntando
tengo una duda más el hecho de estar
participando en este momento me confirma
que estoy inscrito en el programa de
capacitación hay alguna forma de
confirmar de qué forma los chicos
pues ya está inscrito inscripto hará un
estimado a sandra con el hecho de
participar en este webinar y dar
seguimiento a nuestra presentación que
estará recibiendo tu certificado del
módulo 1
por parte de carga de mí
nos comentan los 523 gracias por
permitirme crecer en conocimiento y
aprender cada día gracias a ti lo pita
gracias por darnos la oportunidad
estamos aquí para apoyarte ojala puedas
invitar a otros docentes en la escuela a
unirse a la plataforma de arcade me
recuerda es totalmente gratuita lo único
que tienes que hacer es crear una cuenta
registrarte en nuestro formulario y ya
estás adentro él ya está en nuestro
programa de certificación y nosotros
encantados de poder de apoyar en todo lo
que necesites
crescenciano salinas ruiz nos comenta
hay límite para los
para los alumnos que deben participar en
el campeonato no no hay límite pueden
ser 10 estudiantes 50 estudiantes 100
estudiantes puede ser inclusive hasta
1000 estudiantes todos pueden participar
ahora bien para recibir el certificado
tienes que tener más
de 10 alumnos inscritos con 10 alumnos
es más que suficiente
en el torneo de campeonato por supuesto
y de ahí el número es ilimitado
solamente necesitas registrar a más de
10 alumnos en el campeonato y poder
recibir tu certificado del módulo 2
nos comenta julia isabel becerra lópez
una herramienta muy buena felicidades
por esta labor de apoyo docente gracias
por tus comentarios
julia
nos comenta lizbeth cardanes desde
honduras
me encanta academy es una excelente
forma de aprender
claro que sí que es una herramienta más
para apoyar al docente hacer de su
práctica docente todo un éxito
nos comentábamos que arturo arellano soy
docente del cebetis número 162 en
zitácuaro michoacán michoacán
y espero integrar un club de caracas de
matemáticas el próximo semestre
y claro participar en el campeonato
felicidades oscar arturo una excelente
idea de crear un club
del canaka de mí puede ser por las
tardes puede ser una vez a la semana
puede ser dos veces a la semana de
acuerdo a tus tiempos a las
instalaciones de tu escuela por las
características de sus estudiantes y
pues con el aval de tu director de tu
directora lo único que seguirá será
éxito
y desarrollar mejores habilidades en
matemáticas o en ciencias excelente idea
de crear un club
de canicas de mí en tu escuela
nos comenta blanca márquez gracias por
su gran aportación a mis clases mis
alumnos disfrutan resolviendo retos en
su plataforma lo veo como juego virtual
porque se divierten y obtienen
reconocimientos en su plataforma
así es estarán recibiendo sus
estudiantes premios digitales
e insignias
nos pregunta patricia pérez en caso de
no poder estar en vivo en la próxima
capacitación del 14 de agosto ya no
podrá recibir mi certificado
todavía puedes claro que todavía puedes
porque estamos mandando el vídeo en un
correo con un check list
y recuerden que son tres webinars tres
módulos lo único que estamos pidiendo es
que por lo menos puedes asistir a dos de
ellos
nos pregunta ángeles garcía fechas de
las siguientes videoconferencias ahí
tienes la liga para el programa completo
el bien de las fechas
en el chat está la liga para las
siguientes fechas los siguientes
webinars y los siguientes pasos
y una muy buena pregunta de ricardo
hernández salgado en campeonato pueden
participar alumnos de colegios
particulares la respuesta es sí
participan colegios privados y escuelas
públicas de toda la república mexicana
nos comenta anna media cortázar el
próximo lunes comienzan las clases en
nuestro plantel y sabré cuántos alumnos
integrado en la clase perfecto y pues ya
estarás lista para registrarte en el
reto de campeonato y los que no
si pueden iniciar las clases el 20 de
agosto pues pueden registrar esa misma
semana o la siguiente semana a sus
estudiantes en este gran reto donde
estaremos garantizando diversión
motivación y aprendizaje
desde nuestra plataforma
nos comenta carla estrada excelente
presentación para nuestro crecimiento
profesional
así es carla y toda esta capacitación
para todos los docentes es totalmente
gratuita estarán recibiendo un
certificado de virtual que puedes
imprimir y presentar a sus directivos
pero lo más importante es la
satisfacción personal de saber que estás
actualizando te en nuevas pedagogías
nuevas estrategias y haciendo un uso
adecuado
de las nuevas tecnologías que están a
nuestra mano que están a nuestra
disposición
[Música]
y de esta manera
los más beneficiados serán nuestros
alumnos
es importante que le tomen una foto a
esta última diapositiva o la cara blanca
de mi punto org
para que nos puedan enviar un correo
electrónico si tienen algún problema
técnico necesita un soporte técnico
dudas comentarios quejas felicitaciones
estaremos contentos de recibir todos sus
todos sus correos electrónicos
es importante la retroalimentación para
nosotros
para hacer nuestra plataforma cada día
algo mucho más eficiente mucho más
sencillo de utilizar
entonces pues es muy importante esa
retroalimentación
para nuestra plataforma de jiang zemin
[Música]
nos comenta crecenciano salinas
desgracias por seguir fomentando
nuestros tipos estos tipos de plataforma
y de manera gratuita es una herramienta
muy poderosa que me ha servido mucho
para mis alumnos para mejorar en su
aprendizaje saludos desde huatulco
gracias por tus comentarios y
efectivamente es una herramienta muy
poderosa
en la medida que nosotros podamos
utilizarla
los más beneficiados serán nuestros
alumnos ya que ellos podrán incrementar
sus aprendizajes de manera significativa
nos comenta carlos gracias por la
capacitación
[Música]
y nos dice que también
podrá poner su club
vengan acá venía recuerden todo esto es
opcional depende de la carga de trabajo
que tengan en su escuela
si necesitan algún tipo de soporte
técnico envíanos un correo o la canaca
de mi punto org
si requieren estrategias de cómo
implementar o de cómo llevarlo a cabo
nosotros encantados de apoyarlos
estaba a punto de terminar este
webinario si tienen dudas pueden seguir
utilizando el chat o mandar un correo
electrónico para darle seguimiento a sus
inquietudes
ah
abajo
pues no me resta más que agradecerles
infinitamente por acompañarnos el día de
hoy en este primer webinar de canicas de
mí
soy pedro aparicio que las órdenes que
tengan un excelente día buenas tardes